Çeviri: Orkun Nazim Kadioglu
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Zülal Solak
Madem temamız geçmiş, o hâlde
ben de size geçmişten bir anımı
anlatarak başlamak istiyorum.
7 yaşındayım, o zamanlar
İzmir'de yaşıyorum ailemle.
Annem ve babam çok korumacı tipler.
Ama öyle güvenli de bir
mahallede oturuyoruz ki,
okuldan eve geldiğim zaman sokakta diğer
çocuklarla oynamama müsaade ediyorlar.
Benim yaşıtım
çocuklar ya bisiklete biniyor,
ya ip atlıyor, ya yakar top oynuyor.
Ama bir çocuk var,
benden böyle 5-6 yaş büyük, Eren.
Uzun saçlı, grafiti yapıyor,
Amerika'dan yeni dönmüş.
Kesin de dönüş yapmış yani.
O paten kayıyor, ay çok havalı!
Ben de O'nun gibi olmak istiyorum.
Paten kaymak ve cool olmak.
Annemler sonunda ısrarlarıma dayanmayıp
bana bir çift paten alıyorlar.
Bir de hiç cool olmayan
bir kask, bir dirseklik, dizlik.
Yani bir ABS, hava yastığım ve
can yeleğim eksik öyle söyleyeyim size.
Ama Eren'de bunların hiçbiri yok.
Ya çünkü o çok "cool".
İşte ben de o yüzden,
evden tam teşekküllü çıkıyorum,
ama kaskım, dirsekliğim,
dizliğimi falan bırakıp öyle kayıyorum.
Yine bir gün geldim okuldan eve,
çok da güzel bir bahar
havası var, İzmirliler bilir o havayı.
Çıktım sokağa, sokağın başından sonuna
sonundan başına kayıyorum da kayıyorum.
Eren yok o gün ortalarda.
Ya halbuki tam da
beni görmesi lazım, çünkü
kıvama geldim, hem paten kayıyorum,
hem de çok cool kayıyorum.
Dizliksiz falan.
Neyse, ama yok ortalarda.
Fark ediyorum ki zaten
hava kararmaya başlamış.
Eve dönmem lazım.
Hızlıca evin yolunu tutuyorum.
O zamanlar cam damacanalar vardı,
belki hatırlayanlar vardır aranızda.
Bizim apartmanın önüne indirilirdi
şişeler boşaldığında toplansın diye.
Ben de hem Eren'in gözüne girememiş,
hem de eve geç kalmış
olmanın telaşından olsa gerek,
cam damacalarını görüyorum ama
frene basamıyorum, yavaşlayamıyorum,
kendimi durduramıyorum ve
o 6-7 litrelik cam damacanaların
üzerine düşüyorum.
Ani bir şok yaşamış olacağım ki,
kendime geldiğim zaman
şöyle bir bedenime bakıyorum
ellerim, kollarım, bacaklarım
cam kırıkları içerisinde.
Şişeler paramparça olmuş.
Tabii benim Eren'le
arkadaş olma hayallerim de.
Kan revan içindeyim, öyle titriyorum ki
dişlerim çeneme vuruyor korkudan.
Tam o sırada -bizim tombik
apartman görevlisi Hasan ağabey vardı-
O bana doğru koşuyor, böyle dövünerek
"Ah, Zeynep n'oldu? Hadi hemen hastaneye!"
"Annem" diyorum, yukarıya bakıyorum.
Çünkü o an yanımda
bir tek annemi istiyorum.
Ya, tombik Hasan ağabeyi değil.
Kucaklıyor beni Hasan ağabey,
asansöre bindiriyor,
dördüncü katta oturuyoruz o zamanlar.
Dördüncü kata geliyoruz,
zile basıyor Hasan ağabey.
Kapıyı annem açıyor,
karşısında beni görüyor.
"Ah Zeynep, ne yaptın?" diyor.
"Yavrum, iyi misin?" demiyor.
"Merak etme çocuğum,
haydi hemen hastaneye gidiyoruz"
demiyor.
"Kızım sorun değil, Eren seni
zaten görmemiştir ben eminim"
bile demiyor.
"Ah Zeynep, ne yaptın?" diyor.
Yani sanki ben o şişelerin
üstüne isteyerek düşmüşüm gibi.
O an, şu zihnime
öyle bir kazınmış olacak ki,
şimdi 29 yaşındayım, 20 küsur senedir
ne zaman hata olarak
algılayacağım bir şey yapsam
ne zaman düşsem, paramparça olup dağılsam,
zihnimin içinden çok tanıdık bir ses çıkıp
"Ah Zeynep, ne yaptın?" diyor.
Merak ediyorum.
Sizin zihninizin içinde de
buna benzer bir ses var mı?
Hani, bir hata yaptığınızda,
bir konuda başarısız olduğunuzda,
sizi acımasızca eleştiren, yargılayan,
olanlardan sizi sorumlu
tutan, size tembel olduğunuzu,
başarısız olduğunuzu, güçsüz
olduğunuzu, zayıf olduğunuzu ya da
yeterince zayıf olmadığınızı,
yeterince güzel, yeterince akıllı,
yeterince onlar gibi olmadığınızı söyleyen
bir ses var mı?
Çünkü, eğer varsa bilirsiniz.
Dünya üzerinde hiçbir ses, o sesten
daha acımasız değildir.
İnsan hariç, hiçbir canlı acı çektiğinde
kendine kızmaz.
Korktuğunda kendini aşağılamaz.
Bir şeyler yolunda gitmediği zaman,
kendini suçlayıp cezalandırmaz.
İşte sizlere bugün bahsedeceğim
öz şefkat araştırmaları da
bilhassa zihnimizin içindeki o
eleştirel iç sesten bahsediyor.
Peki nedir öz şefkat?
Öz şefkat, çok basitçe
kişinin kendine de sevdiği,
değer verdiğine birine davrandığı
şekilde davranması demektir.
Kişinin kendine de,
bilhassa zor durumlarda,
acı çektiği durumlarda, ihtiyacı
olan anlayışı, kabulü,
şefkati vermesi demektir.
Fakat, maalesef öz şefkat
çoğumuza yabancı gelir.
Çünkü maalesef çoğumuz,
korkutmanın, cezanın, eleştirilmenin
çok sık kullanıldığı ortamlarda büyüyoruz.
Mesela burada, herhâlde 2 bin kişiyiz,
kaçınız çocukken bir davranışınızı
değiştirmeniz konusunda
korku ile motive edildiniz?
"O tabağındaki yemekler bitmezse
bir daha sana yemek vermem!"
"Arkandan ağlar!"
Benim için bu çok korkunçtu,
yemeklerin arkamdan ağlaması, mesela...
Ya da kaçınız, kontrolü elinizde olmayan
duygu ve düşüncelerinizin
yüzünden utandırıldınız?
"Çocuğum, nereden geliyor aklına böyle
saçma sapan düşünceler? Düşünme!"
"Korkma evladım, ne var korkulacak bunda?"
Tanıdık geliyor mu?
Ebeveynlerimiz bize bu şekilde konuştukça,
biz de kendimize
bu şekilde konuşmaya başlarız.
Çocuklar aynı zamanda
gözlemleyerek de öğrenirler.
Direkt olarak eleştiriye
maruz kalmanız gerekmez.
Eğer büyüdüğünüz ortamda
kendini sıkça eleştiren biri varsa,
onu gözlemleyerek, onun
davranışlarını da kopyalayabilirsiniz.
Bakın, kültürün de çok
önemli bir payı vardır.
Atlamak istemiyorum,
atasözlerine kulak verelim.
Bu coğrafyada
"kızını dövmeyen, dizini döver"
diye bir atasözü var.
Bu atasözünde denmek istenen şu:
Yarın bir gün, evladın bir hata
yapar üzülür, sıkıntı çekerse,
sen de çok üzülürsün.
Şimdi bu kadar güzel bir niyet,
ancak bu kadar berbat bir
şekilde özetlenebilir.
Yani ya sevdiğimiz birini dövüyoruz
ya kendimizi dövüyoruz.
Çünkü başka yolu yok hatalarımızdan
ders alabilmenin.
Hadi kökenlerini anladık.
Peki bu içimizdeki agresif, cezalandırıcı,
yargılayıcı iç sesin amacı ne?
Ne yapmaya çalışıyor?
Mesela annem, beni o şekilde
acı çekerken gördüğü zaman
bana neden öyle sert bir tepki vermişti?
Beni sevmediğinden mi?
Hayır.
Bakın kendisi şuralarda bir yerlerde
oturuyor, çok göremiyorum ama
bu dünyada beni o kadından
daha fazla seven kimse yok.
Peki, benim daha fazla acı
çekmemi istediğinden mi?
Hayır.
"Zeynep, aklım yerinden çıktı o
hâlde seni gördüğümde"
dedi bana yıllar sonra bu olay
üzerinde konuştuğumuzda.
Bir de baktım ki, kaskını da takmamışsın.
Çocuğum, ya daha kötü bir şey
gelseydi başına?
Ben o zaman ne yapardım?
Annem korkmuştu.
Ve beni daha temkinli olmaya
davet ediyordu.
Beni korumaya çalışıyordu.
Ve bunu da bildiği tek yolla yapıyordu.
Kızarak, korkutarak, suçlayarak.
İşte, içimizdeki eleştirel
iç sesin de amacı aynı.
Bizi korumaya çalışmak.
Bizi güvende ve hayatta tutmak.
Çünkü o da korkuyor.
Hata yapmamızdan, başarısız olmamızdan,
yalnız kalmamızdan,
acı çekmemizden korkuyor.
O yüzden cezamızı çekelim istiyor ki,
bir daha aynı hatayı yapmayalım.
Korkalım ki, bir daha daha
temkinli davranalım.
Yine aynı acıyı yaşamayalım.
Herkeslerden önce hatamızı, eksiğimizi
o bulsun ki, kimselere öyle
hazırlıksız yakalanmayalım,
bizim canımız öyle kolay kolay yanmasın.
İşte o yüzden bir yanım kendime
nasıl daha fazla şefkatle
davranacağımı öğrenmek için
yanıp tutuşurken,
bir yanım da bir direnç gösteriyordu
öz şefkata karşı.
Çünkü kendime şefkat gösterirsem
hata yapacağımdan korkuyordum.
Dahası o yaptığım hataların umrumda
olmayacağından korkuyordum.
Şımarık biri, bencil biri, dahası tembel
biri olacağımdan korkuyordum.
Zaten ertelemeye çok meyilli
bir insan olarak ben
nasıl motive edebilirdim ki kendimi
kendime şefkatle davranırsam?
Buraya nasıl geldiysem, hani çok matah
bir yer değil belki ama
hani neler başardıysam,
onu o içimdeki eleştirel iç sese borçlu
olduğumu zannediyordum.
Bu kadar büyük bir direnç gösterdiğimi
katıldığım ilk öz şefkat
atölyesinde fark ettim.
İşte teorik eğitim bittikten sonra
grup liderimiz günü bir meditasyon
etkinliği ile kapamamızı önerdi.
Geçirdi hepimiz rahat bir pozisyona,
gözlerimizi kapattı,
klasik şeyler bunlar.
Ondan sonra şöyle hepimiz rahat bir
pozisyona geçip gözlerimizi kaparken
meditasyonun ikinci üçüncü
dakikasına doğru
grup liderinden şöyle bir yönerge geldi:
şimdi eğer sizin için de uygunsa
bir elinizi alın ve avucunu nazikçe
kalbinizin üzerine yerleştirin.
Haydaa...
Hani...
Aldı mı benim eleştirel iç ses sazı eline.
Şaka herhâlde?
Hani, yapmayacaksın öyle
bir şey değil mi?
Ya, senin arkadaşların ders
veriyor, makaleler yazıyorlar,
araştırmalar yapıyorlar, biraz
kassalar profesör olacaklar.
Senin burada işin ne? Ne yapıyorsun sen?
Şöyle kapalı olan gözlerimden bir
tanesini açtım, etrafa bakıyorum.
Herkes koymuş mu elini kalbinin üstüne.
Ben hariç.
Kiminin gözlerinden yaşlar falan akıyor.
Ama, mümkün değil, benim elim çok
yadırgıyor kalbimin üstünde olmayı.
Bu sefer de başladı mı, bu kadar
basit bir şeyi bile yapamıyorsun.
İnanamıyorum sana, acınacak durumdasın.
Zaten ben o kadar girmişim ki
o içsel diyaloğumun içine,
ancak meditasyon çanının çalıp
bitmesiyle kendime geldim.
Sonra herkes yavaş yavaş
toparlanmaya başlarken,
grup liderinin yanına gittim,
kendimi tanıttım.
Dedim ki, hocam bakın,
sakın yanlış anlamayın ama
bu son yaptığımız egzersiz bana biraz
böyle saçma geldi, komik geldi açıkçası.
Ben daha bilimsel bir şeyler arıyorum.
O yüzden ben elimi kalbimin
üstüne falan öyle şeyler yapamadım.
Yüzünde böyle çok sıcacık
bir gülümseme ile bana,
"Çok doğal bir tepki veriyorsun" dedi.
"Çünkü alışkın
olmadığın bir şey deniyorsun"
Ve sonra, kıymetini her
geçen gün daha iyi anladığım
ve kendime sıkça hatırlatmaya
niyet ettiğim bir şey daha söyledi
"Ama" dedi, "bazen zihnine
komik veya saçma gelen bir şey
bedenine iyi gelebilir,
dilersen bir şans daha ver."
O akşam döndüm eve.
Bize kendi kendimize
uygulamamız için verilen
meditasyon CD'sini taktım
bilgisayarıma, açtım yoga matımı,
oturdum ortasına, gözlerimi kapadım ve
zihnimin tüm eleştirileri
ile birlikte, merakla
birlikte ne olacağına
dair, aldım o elimi ve
yadırgaya yadırgaya
kalbimin üstüne koydum.
Meğerse egzersiz şöyle devam ediyormuş:
Şimdi farz edin ki,
o kalbinizin üzerindeki el, size değil de
başka birine ait.
Anlayışlı, duyarlı,
bilge, şefkatli birine ait.
Sizin ne kadar üzüldüğünüzü,
ne kadar korktuğunuzu,
ne kadar endişelendiğinizi
bilen birine ait.
Artık daha fazla acı
çekmenizi istemeyen birine ait.
İyi olmanızı, güvende
olmanızı isteyen birine ait.
Ne yapmış olursanız
olun, sizi tüm hatalarınızla,
tüm kusurlarınızla birlikte, kabul eden,
dahası seven birine ait.
Şimdi o elin sahibi,
bu zor anınıza ortaklık ederken,
size neler söylesin isterdiniz?
Tam da şu anda,
ne duymaya ihtiyacınız var?
Ev, bildiğim yerden kilometrelerce uzakta,
New York'ta tek başıma yaşadığım
küçücük evimin salonunun ortasında
bir mor yoga matının üstünde
hüngür hüngür ağlamaya başladım.
İçimden yumuşacık bir ses bana
"yanındayım" diyordu.
"Geçecek, sen elinden
gelenin en iyisini yapıyorsun."
O günden sonra, pılımı pırtımı toplayıp
Hindistan'a yerleşmedim, vegan olmadım,
bir ağacın altında oturup günümün
yarısını meditasyon yaparak geçirmedim.
Çünkü benim aradığım
nirvanaya ulaşılamıyormuş.
Ama o günden sonra, bir şey değişti.
Çünkü ben o gün elimi
aldım ve kalbimin üzerine koydum
ve kendime normalde
hiç söylemeyeceğim şeyleri
aylardır, belki yıllardır
başkalarından duymak istediğim şeyleri
kendi kulağıma fısıldadım
ve bu benim kalbimi açtı.
Bu bende fizyolojik bir
reaksiyona sebep oldu.
Bunun bilimsel bir açıklaması olmalıydı.
Ve o günden sonra ben,
psikolog Paul Gilbert
ve Kristin Neff sayesinde,
öz şefkatin bilimsel
yönünü araştırmaya başladım.
Meğerse bizim zihnimiz
mutluluk için tasarlanmamış.
Bizim zihnimiz bizi hayatta
tutmak için tasarlanmış.
Ve bizi hayatta tutan iki mekanizma var.
Bunlardan birincisi: Tehdit
ve savunma mekanizması.
Bu mekanizma herhangi bir tehlike ile
veya tehdit ile baş başa
kaldığımız zaman aktive olur.
Örneğin, size doğru
hızla gelen bir arabanın
kornasının sesini duyduğunuz zaman.
Ve vücudumuzda bir takım
değişiklikler oluşmaya başlar.
Sempatik sinir sistemimiz devreye girer,
vücudumuz adrenalin ve kortizol
hormonları salgılamaya başlar,
kalp atışlarımız hızlanır,
solunumumuz hızlanır, kaslarımız gerililr,
aynı zamanda zihnimizde de
bir takım değişiklikler olmaya başlar.
Muhakeme yetimiz örselenir,
farkındalık alanımız daralır.
Tüm bu değişiklikler, bizi,
o tehdit olarak gördüğümüz şeyle
savaşmaya veya ondan kaçmaya hazırlar.
Fakat, bu mekanizma
yalnızca fiziksel bir saldırıyla
karşı karşıya kaldığımızda devreye girmez.
Tehdit ve savunma
mekanizmamız, duygusal bir saldırıyla
karşı karşıya
kaldığımızda da devreye girer.
Ve kendimizi acımasızca eleştirdiğimizde,
kendimize acımasızca konuştuğumuzda,
yaptığımız, kendimize
duygusal bir saldırıdır.
Bizi hayatta tutan ikinci mekanizma ise,
tüm memelilerde, insanlar dâhil
tüm memelilerde görebileceğimiz
yatıştırma ve bakım verme mekanizmasıdır.
Memeli bebekler,
doğduklarında bakıma muhtaçtırlar
ve hayatta kalabilmesi için
en fazla bakıma muhtaç duyan
memeli türü de insandır.
Ve, bizim sütten çok daha fazlasına
ihtiyacımız vardır
hayatta kalabilmek için.
Bağ kurmaya, sıcaklığa,
temasa ihtiyacımız vardır.
Memeli ebeveynler
bebekleriyle bağ kurmaya,
onları yatıştırmaya programlıdır
ve işin en tatlı yanı da
memeli bebekler de
kendilerini güvende hissetmek için
ebeveynleriyle bağ
kurmaya programlıdırlar.
Bu sistem aktive olduğu zaman
sempatik sinir sistemimiz
devre dışı kalır,
parasempatik sistemimiz devreye girer.
Vücudumuz oksitosin adında
bir hormon salgılamaya başlar,
ki bu hormon,
sevdiğiniz biri size sarıldığında
salgıladığınız hormondur.
Kalp atışlarınız yavaşlar,
solunumuz yavaşlar,
kaslarımız gevşer, olaylara daha
geniş bir perspektiften bakabiliriz.
Çünkü yatışmışızdır artık.
Kendimizi acımasızca eleştirdiğimizde,
tehdit ve savunma
mekanizmamız devreye girer.
Kendimize şefkatle yaklaştığımızda ise,
bakım verme ve yatıştırma mekanizması.
Bakım verme ve yatıştırma
mekanizmasının kapısını üç şey aralar:
-bu iyi bir haber bakın,
çünkü eğer sizin de zihniniz
benimki gibi şefkate
gitmekte direnç gösteriyorsa,
bu üç şeyi kullanıp bedeninizi
şefkate götürebilirsiniz-
nazik bir dokunuş,
fiziksel sıcaklık,
yumuşak bir ses tonu.
İşte o şefkatli el egzersizi benim için
bu yüzden o kadar kuvvetliydi.
Çünkü, bu saydığım üç şeyin
üçü de bir aradaydı.
Benim yatıştırma ve bakım verme
mekanizmamı aktive etmişti.
Peki, kimdi o sözleri
söyleyen bana içimden?
Bana o şefkati, anlayışı veren kimdi?
İşte o benim şefkatli yanımdı.
Biz, şefkat vermeyi sandığımızdan
çok daha iyi biliyoruz.
Sevdiğimiz biri acı
çektiğinde, ona ne söylersek iyi gelir?
Ona nasıl yaklaşsak
iyi gelir, çok iyi biliyoruz.
İçimizdeki bu kaynakları
kendimiz için de kullanabiliriz.
Eğer siz de öz şefkata
bir şans vermek isterseniz,
bir dahaki sefere acı
ziyaretinize geldiğinde,
ondan kaçmak, onu dönüştürmeye çalışmak
veya acı çektiğiniz için
kendinize kızmak yerine,
belki bu üç şeyden yararlanıp,
elinizi götürüp kalbinizin
üzerine, acınızı da yüzünüzü dönüp,
kendinize "şu an zor bir an,
kendime nasıl yardımcı olabilirim?"
diye sorabilirsiniz.
Bu soru, yumuşak olduğu
kadar, cesurdur da aynı zamanda.
Çünkü acının varlığını
kabul etmek, ona yer açıp
onunla birlikte harekete geçmek,
cesaret gerektirir.
Öz şefkat, hem nezaket, hem cesarettir.
Öz şefkat, herkesin acı çektiği,
acının kaçınılmaz olduğu bu hayatta,
kendi kendimize destek çıkmaktır,
kendi elimizden tutmaktır.
İşte bu yüzden öz şefkat,
hem paylaşılmaya, hem de inanın,
şans verilmeye değer bir fikir.
Çok teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)